now there's a very important threshold
question here in order for the sec to
become involved in the regulation of
crypto remember the sec's name is the
securities and exchange commission we
have to cross the definitional barrier
of being able to define the crypto as a
security
so that raises the question what's
security
now what's interesting is if you look at
the statutes the organic statutes the
securities act of 1933 and the
securities and exchange act of 1934
each contains a section that defines
what a security is
and the definitions look pretty
pedestrian and obvious
they talk about stock they talk about
bonds they talk about other instruments
that most of us would recognize as
clearly being securities
but they then throw in a phrase called
investment contract
what the heck is an investment contract
well the investment contract is what i
call a rubber phrase
it's flexible
and it's designed to capture
arrangements that act like securities
but don't fit comfortably within any of
the other categories of securities
needless to say whenever you have a
flexible term in a statute
a fact pattern is going to arise that's
going to challenge the flexible term
it's going to call on the courts to
apply that flexible term to a specific
set of circumstances
the first time that issue arose before
the united states supreme court was in
1946
with regard to a case called sec versus
howie
the securities and exchange commission
brought a case against the developer of
orange groves
who wound up selling interests
in the orange grove
combined with a land management contract
and this is a very important distinction
what you would have
is tourists come down to florida in the
1930s and 1940s
they would stay at this fancy hotel
and right next to the hotel there would
be signs and brochures saying you love
it here in florida in the summer why
don't you buy a piece of our orange
grove here
and the important point is that what the
tourists were buying
wasn't the orange
it wasn't even the tree
it was the combination
of the citrus the rights to the prophets
of the citrus with the management
contract
it was the package that the supreme
court decided satisfied the definition
of an investment contract
and because that investment contract was
not registered with the sec
and because the sellers couldn't
demonstrate that they qualified for an
exemption
the supreme court agreed with the
securities exchange commission and it
said that the combination of the sale of
the orange grove
with the management contract
was a security
the supreme court at no point held and
this is really important
that an orange
was a security
it was the package that was the security